تقتربوا الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا من
شهرها التاسع الا ان المخاض لا يبدو قريبا
فالطرفاني لا يقتربان من وضع حد لاول حرب
في اوروبا منذ عقود
بالرغم من التصريحات الروسيه التي لا
تمانع مفاوضات السلام يبدو الطرف
الاوكراني فاقدا للثقه بجاره الشرقيه
وترفض كيف ان ترى الهدنه القصيره خطوه نحو
انهاء الحرب بل تنظر اليها كف فرصه تختنها
روسيا استعاده قواها بعد الخسائر التي
منيت بها عقب استعاده القوات الاخرانيه
السياده على بعض المناطق كخرسون رشا
تبحث روسيا الان عن هدنه قصيره وفتره راحه
لاستعاده القوه قد يسمي شخص ما هذا نهايه
الحرب لكن مثل هذه المهله لن تؤدي الا الى
تفاقم الوضع
كيف وبعد استغلالها نقاط ضعف روسيا اشترطت
على موسكو سحب قوتها من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه مقابل الانخراط في مفاوضات
سلام اما الحليفه واشنطن ترفض اي نوع من
الضغط يدفع اوكرانيا نحو الحوار
شروط اعتبرتها موسكو غير واقعيه متهمه كيف
بالتسويف السلام في ظل المعطيات يبدو
افقوا الازمه الاوكرانيه الضبابيا لكن
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
مخاوف اوكرانيا من هدنه او مفاوضات السلام
عزيزتها تصريحات واشنطن على لسان جيك
سوليفان مستشار الامن القومي الذي ربط
خيار وقف ثياب للقتال بنهايه اوكرانيا هبه
عمر العربيه